[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an après difficile de faire un
diagnostic économique du départ des
anglais de lui car la pandémie fausse
quelque peu le résultat sur son sol
après une récession énorme en 2020 de
près de 10% la plus forte des pays du g7
en 2021 la grande bretagne a vu arriver
le rebond économique au deuxième
trimestre la croissance était de 5,5
pour cent au troisième elle a fortement
ralenti pour atteindre 1,3 pour cent
cela s'expliquerait en partie par une
difficultés rencontrées tout au long de
l'année les pénuries surtout de
personnel en particulier de chauffeurs
routiers
selon la fédération des transporteurs le
pays manque actuellement de 100 1000
conducteurs ceux qui causent donc des
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour des
produits alimentaires ou pour le
carburant et ralentissent la reprise
d'activité les pénuries de main d'oeuvre
ont également touché bon nombre d'autres
métiers et atteint des records dès la
moitié de 2021 avec près d'un million de
postes vacants la faute à la fois au
vide et au brésil qui aurait poussé bon
nombre de travailleurs étrangers souvent
européen à rentrer chez eux le breakbeat
aura néanmoins permis sur un plan
international au pays de trouver de
nouvelles alliances commerciales avec
israël tout récemment ou l'australie
vous rappelez le contrat des sous marins
perdus par la france au profit des usa
et du royaume uni à côté de cela les
désaccords et les conflits avec le et
surtout la france ont continué de
s'accentuer
que ce soit sur la crise migratoire ou
la pêche par exemple reste également le
problème de l'irlande du nord qui a
gardé son accès au marché européen
ce que l'on aimerait re négocier tandis
que bruxelles refuse catégoriquement
bref un an après la grande bretagne
semble avoir pris plus que jamais ses
distances avec le e même si son économie
rencontre également de grosses
difficultés pour s'adapter